oh
so
tom sheldon
well i guess you got my message
it's all clear meter i'm on my way
who's that
why are you here sheldon
when you went dark after medici i
figured i'd look through some of your
old files see where you might end up
turns out your dad was working with
oscar espinoza back in the day
something called project iapa
what do you know about iapa
i know there's lots of buzz about soliz
at the agency these days talk of weather
modification technology strategic
atmospherics
of course once the higher-ups heard that
i was looking at those iopa files
i ended up on administrative leave
guess i'm not the only one who doesn't
trust tom sheldon
i know you're looking to take out a
yapper rico
i've already done some of the legwork
you screwed me over more than once in
medicine
i don't want your help sheldon well
you're gonna need it
i did some snooping around zone a dose
turns out that place is constantly
surrounded by a nasty lightning storm
fried poor annabelle here
that seems pretty suspicious to have a
standing lightning storm like that don't
you think
this a friend of yours rico
not exactly
mire morales this is tom sheldon
known him for 20 years
you cannot be trusted
buenas
don't listen to this guy senorita
pleased to meet you
enrico and i were just discussing the
situation with zona dos and you know how
to access decor
i don't know anything about the core but
i got a good idea how to get us past
that lightning storm
good luck with annabelle sheldon
we'll figure something else out
he's got a plan rico
and we don't
duck
okay
now there's a river that runs underneath
the facility i figured we use a boat to
get close you remember the stingray base
bag of medici the same basic concept you
want to make a lightning proof boat yeah
bingo
now i also hear there's a nearby
research lab that's testing a way to
harness lightning figure we find
something there to protect the boat
spares poor annabelle's fate you're
talking about that facility in the
mountains mariola you got it
and we could do the custom boat work at
prospero astiero
interesting yeah coming around aren't
you why are you doing this sheldon
well
because i owe you rico
you want to take outiapa
i want to help you do it
besides we both know we can't have just
anybody running around with a weather
weapon for god's sakes
you got a better idea
[ __ ]
that's what i like to hear
so
we meet up at medio lab when we're ready
sounds good
you know for a minute there i thought
you were gonna shoot me
not this time sheldon
you